alors est ce qui t'arrive de lire des
vrais livres pourquoi pas et puis j'ai
fini jamais rien pourquoi définis-tu
jamais essayé m'expliquer si j'ai la
flemme du tavini est ce que tu penses
c'est parce que tu as encore très jeune
ou est ce que tu penses que tu auras
jamais envie de lire dans ta vie moi
j'aurais peut-être envie non pas pour
l'instant ça j'ai pas envie qu'est ce
que tu préfères faire plutôt que de lire
la musique est ce que tu trouves c'est
important de lire oui on part on me le
dit chercher il dit ça se voit oui tu
trouves que je dis je pas assez
cependant conseillé de lire parce que ce
serait beaucoup pour les études enfin
monsieur mais à l'irb au fait qu'est ce
que tu lis en général quand tu es disons
chez toi pas en place ses doigts d
illustrer case illustre pif babar un
coup mickey pourquoi ça fait ça pour
passer le temps les illustrés souvent
c'est par exemple communiquer c'est à
suivre alors je suis impatiente un peu
savoir le racer ça m'énerve
sinon à astérix tintin lucky luke mais
tes parents te demande de te demande pas
de lire autre chose
6 et alors qu'est ce qui t'arrive de
lire des vrais livres les aventures
d'animaux les livres de sport
d'alpinisme man tu as quel âge deux ans
et que lit tu généralement beaucoup de
livres d'aventurés pas beaucoup
d'illustrés de lille de deux aventures
de bree journaux et des mystères puis
beaucoup de livres de jules verne
ensuite j'aime bien ça moi je vis des
roms une aventure puis eu parfois des
des livres de la comtesse de ségur
moi je lis déclin 17d club des cinq
enfin les livres qui a dans les rues
principales sont des enfants de mon âge
d histoire d' aventure des histoires
comiques
ah bon comics quoi comme base qu'est ce
qui te fait rire alors c'est moi des
choses que tu as lu équité fait rire je
voudrais surtout des trompes et le
docteur knock pour vos échéances elles
sont le tort d'être trimestriels dans un
climat où le client est annuelle du bois
est ce que tu comprends bien ce que tu
dis là
j'aime bien les histoires tristes aussi
comme la soeur de gribouille
alors il ya deux morts d'un livre enfin
c'était mou venge ce qui est arrivé de
pleurer en disant oui plusieurs fois
est-ce que tu as mais ce qu'est ce que
tu lis plus facilement des livres
destinés aux filles où tu dis n'importe
quoi enfin le porte-voix je trouve je ne
trouve pas qu'il ya une littérature qui
est plus particulièrement réservée aux
petites filles ou jeunes filles dont
j'ai lu des livres sur les la marine ce
qui m'a appris à faire beaucoup de
neubourg
tu veux te voir en bas âge en fait je
fais de la voile pour mon plaisir
je lis beaucoup même mes parents me
retienne parce que sinon vivre les
livres
est ce que tu peux les bretons l'étoile
et plusieurs par semaine oui si si on me
laissait gens n'iraient plusieurs par
semaine à quoi tu penses quand tu dis
comme ça tu es vraiment plongés dans ton
livre tu cites arrive de penser à autre
chose tu mais combien de temps pour lire
allez vous généralement plus vite
possible
2h30 ou trois heures sa défense qu'il y
en a qui sont plus gros buzz quand il ya
des choses où tu ne comprends pas très
bien dans un livre ça peut peut-être
arriver à ce que tu cherches à te faire
expliquer aux noms je continue je
préfère jouer puis en vacances ne l'est
pas non pas tellement pendant les
vacances je lis le soir d'ailleurs mes
parents préfèrent que je dise que de
regarder la télévision
enfin quand je dis pas souvent enfants
parce que j'en profite
aubin jeudi et pendant les vacances je
lis issoire maman à une grande
bibliothèque alors qu'est ce qui
t'arrive de prendre des livres dans
ludothèque de ton père parce que tu as
envie de lire des choses qui ne sont
peut être défendu
non pas du tout jamais c'est toi qui
choisis ce que tu lis est interdite
d'agir question les choses interdites à
tournage puisque on dit quand c'est
interdit tu ne cherches pas à lire
balassa des portes
et la série des angélique ma mère m'a
dit c'est pas tellement pourquoi mon bas
ça fait nuit ni de gel les prix tu dois
lui le capitaine fracasse
mais j'ai commencé à lire et ce qui m'a
beaucoup plu je l' ai vu un film puis
j'ai voulu me rendre compte si c'était
vraiment la vérité
alors quand j'ai vu un film jeudi le
livre après pour voir cette qu'il
capitaine fracasse vélo théophile
gautier a bien été tu aimes ce genre de
livre oui j'aime bien les films de
cadets cape et d'épée il ya du mouvement
j'aime beaucoup ça tu préfères les films
que la lecture là oui quand même
enfin j'aime bien me rendre compte par
les livres ce que vaut le film ah bon
c'est bizarre ça commence comme démarche
explique moi un peu ça parce que les
fines sais pas comment vous expliquer
mais il invite riche un peu tandis que
les livres tout est expliqué on peut
bien se rendre compte
cite moi non d'un moteur qui équipe par
an qui tue très connue à l'heure
actuelle inhibiteur projet bozon je sais
pas moi oui marcel pagnol tchéquie c'est
non qu'est ce qu'ils achètent ce livre
c'est toi qui économisent pour 13h et
ossètes et par an et par an mais est-ce
que c'est eux qui te force à lire aux
sétois qui les demandent je demande
souvent j'ai acheté le château de mon
père est souvent notre professeur de
français nous dire premier livre est
intéressant ou chose comme ça est ce que
ton professeur te conseille dans tes
lectures il dit quoi
il nous a conseillé de lire des livres
de marcel pagnol
il évolue non tu commencé la gloire de
mon père mais je trouve acceptait ce
n'était pas plaisant c'est est barbant
parce que nous racontait il y avait tout
un temps mort où nous expliquait alors
j'ai abandonné puis j'ai commencé le
château de ma mère
alors là ça m'a plu parce que on
commence tout de suite dans l'histoire
et puis c'est celle aventures d'un petit
garçon qui passe ses vacances à la
campagne et toute cette aventure serait
aussi bien pu nous arriver
alors j'aime bien est ce que tu pense
d'ailleurs que le lire
c'est plus destiné aux filles qu'aux
garçons n'ont pas du tout au contraire
les garçons comme les filles ça les
instruit
parce qu'on l'ait jamais assez instruits
tu pense oui
[Musique]